[Music]
it is standard advice in colder climates
this time of year to make sure you put
on a warm coat before heading outside
but the sad fact is not everyone has
access to one and that includes far too
many kids now one organization is
marking an incredible Milestone the
delivery of its 5 millionth free coat to
a child in need Nikki Batiste has the
story
these may look like ordinary boxes but
what's inside them is extraordinary
hundreds of free coats for children in
need a tagline has become more than a
coat we're really providing emotional
warmth the we is Operation War form
started by dick Sanford 24 years ago
here in Pennsylvania I noticed half a
dozen children who were waiting for a
school bus it was a really really cold
winter day and just struck me what are
they doing outside without a coat that
first year Sanford bought coats for 58
children operation warm now makes them
and this event marks a huge milestone
helping its 5 millionth child how are
you feeling about getting a brand new
coat
before I don't get cold
the kids can take home new shoes too
there are about 800 000 children on the
waiting list on a scale of one to ten
how excited are you
if the smile on Jocelyn's faces any
measure the gift of giving is priceless
for CBS Saturday morning Nikki Batiste
West Grove Pennsylvania
I love that they're new coats you know
so often we see these code giveaways of
gently worn coats which is which is
which is also great but I just love this
idea oh the joy of their faces yeah you
just said incredible I remember getting
a kid getting a coat it's it's a big
deal I know I know great great great
thing the smile yes that says it all
yeah